[موسيقى]
[موسيقى
] هل تفاجأتم يا رفاق
بشعبية البرنامج في العالم العربي
نعم كثيرًا ، لا أعني
فقط في العالم العربي ، أعني
أننا مخادعون صغيرون لدينا بلد كبير
ولكننا  بلد صغير
وهذا العرض كان مخصصًا
للجماهير الإسبانية ،
لذا فإن حقيقة أن
الكثير من الإزعاج لطريقة الحياة الإسبانية
وطريقة الحديث التي تم
تصويرها في العرض
بالنسبة لي يذهلني أنه يسافر إلى
المملكة العربية السعودية إلى الفلبين  من إندونيسيا
إلى الأرجنتين ،
أنت تعلم أنه من الجنون جدًا كيف يمكننا
توصيل
[موسيقى] ،
إنها مزيج من المشاعر تبعث على
الارتياح للعمل الذي تم إجراؤه جيدًا
والنتيجة
متحمسة لمعرفة كيف سيستقبلها الجمهور
والعاطفة والحزن
لأنك تعلم  سنتخذ طرقًا مختلفة ،
وسنظل على اتصال ،
لكنها لن تكون هي نفسها
[الموسيقى]
لذا كانت
سيئة للغاية في الموسم الأول والثاني
، ثم لسبب ما أعتقد أن
الناس اعتادوا على ارتورو  وقد
تضاءل ولكنه حصل بالفعل  آري
في وقت من الأوقات كنت مثل الرجال ، هذا
خيال من أجل الله ، نعم أنت تعرف لماذا
أنا لست أرتورو أنا إنريكي ،
لماذا عليك أن تهددني بإهانتني
[موسيقى]
إنه رائع لذا
أنا أحب إنريكي
أريد  لقتل
أرتورو وأنا أحب هذا الرجل ،
أحب أرتورو وأكره إنريكي لكن علي
أن أتحدث إلى طبيبي النفسي
حول ذلك.